un banc de l'union pour emmanuel macron
c'était hier soir à dijon les militants
dans marche fait la victoire de leur
mouvement en tête au premier tour
certains ont même encore du mal à croire
au chemin parcouru en un an seulement
on est petit à petit est arrivé à la
troisième place d'abord et puis ensuite
on les aime il faut qu'on soit deuxième
faut qu'on se qualifie
et puis quand on était deuxième on
disait il faut qu'on soit en tête on
peut pas laisser
[Applaudissements]
ce soir on est en tête c'est formidable
très ému au lendemain de la victoire
d'emmanuel macro françois de sail est
aussi le président du modem de côte-d'or
qui espèrent depuis longtemps pour voir
la famille centriste gagné les élections
en 2007 j'ai cru françois bayrou elle et
y arriver on m'a dit non ça sera jamais
en france d'utopie c'est un rêve en tout
cas mon rêve devient réalité aujourd'hui
je me dis c'est génial je vais le vivre
on n'est pas là pour défendre un parti
on est là pour défendre un projet défend
des idées et travaillé pour la france
et si on peut rassembler des gens de
gauche et de droite modérée et les
centristes bien sûr ensemble à
travailler pour la france et s'est rendu
ce moment est même qualifiée
d'historique par tous ceux qui
soutiennent emmanuel macron et en
particulier jean yves caullet le
député-maire ps d'avalon qui a rallié le
mouvement en marche au début de l'année
il ya encore six mois je me souviens des
gens qui parlaient d'une bulle donc le
sentiment que l'objectif d'être premiers
à l'issue du premier tour était atteint
et qu'il nous restait beaucoup de
travail à faire pour confirmer consolidé
entraîner davantage de français sur le
projet lui-même et constituer ensuite la
majorité nécessaire à sa mise en oeuvre
mais avant même de construire cette
majorité présidentielle emmanuel macron
devra déjà l'emporté nettement le 7 mai
prochain et rassembler bien au-delà de
ses soutiens